>> Laura: IT'S NOW TIME FOR
OUR "SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT
WHERE WE EXPLORE SOME OF THE BIG
CULTURAL STORIES THE DAY.
NOW, IN A MOMENT WE WILL DIVE
INTO A POLITICAL AMERICAN MUSIC
AWARDS.
BUT FIRST, LAST FRIDAY SEGMENT
WITH RAYMOND ARROYO WENT VIRAL,
MADE INTERNATIONAL HEADLINES.
WE CALL IT A SOCIAL MEDIA
DEBATE.
IS IT AN ACCIDENT OR A COMEDY
BIT?
YOUR    THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT AMBULANCE
CHASER LAWYERS OUT THERE.
>> I'M GLAD I HAVE THIS MOMENT
BECAUSE I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THE REALITY AND THE TRUTH.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WATCH
THIS VIRAL VIDEO AND SAW WHAT
HAPPENED AND THOSE TWO GENTLEMEN
OVER THERE THAT YOU HAVEN'T MET,
MR. BIDDLE AND MR. BILLINGS
WORTH, THOSE ARE MY ATTORNEYS.
YOU WILL MEET THEM AFTER THE
SHOW.
I WILL SHOW THE AUDIENCE A VIDEO
OF WHAT HAPPENED LAST WEEK.
NOW I WANT YOU TO KEEP YOUR EYE
ON LAURA INGRAHAM'S RIGHT HAND,
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS.
ROLL THE TAPE.
>> GO TO THE EDGE.
>> THE ACLU USE TO CARE ABOUT
THE RIGHTS OF THE ACCUSED.
>> YOU THREW ME DOWN AND SUBJECT
CRUEL, HEARTLESS -- I THOUGHT,
I'M GOING TO SLAP YOU WITH -- >>
WHAT DID THEY TAKE?
>> YOUR KIDS WILL BE PAYING MY
PERSONAL INJURY CLAIM WHEN I'M
DONE.
IT I CAN'T STOP WATCHING THIS.
AND I FREAKED OUT AND LAUGHED,
AND I'M SORRY, IT WAS FUNNY.
AT THE SAME TIME I WAS GOING
HOLY [BLEEP].
I HOPE IT WAS FAKE.
BUT NOW WE CAN TELL THE TRUTH.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THAT BRACE, YOU
BOUGHT THAT AT LIKE CVS AN HOUR
AGO.
AND WE ARE NOT EXPECTING THAT,
EITHER.
>> THIS -- THESE PROTESTS AT THE
BEGINNING.
PEOPLE LIKE, OH LAURA, YOU ARE